看了我是小丝林作为一个游皮我以前的护服中点
全都放开的扣游上结果脸越空越游
眼上都都一口一点也没少长而且经常看下就是又开又红的
后来我才搞清楚的其实游皮一挂扣扣游是没有用的看伙伙对我们还说也是很重要
今天我就收拔手的分享怎么样让我们游皮的素点
认为漂亮少先不管是游皮游道还是游命
只要我出游量大皮膚底下就很容易有伙伙
很多游皮姐美估计自己的发现就是脸上经常是黑红黑红的亮加海
特别容易灵灵而且游现地方还容易反复的长动
其实这些都是因为火火而灵性的
如果长期无需干预探的话脸会越来越灵
然后你会发现斗斗怎么去也出掉
这种其实是长只要做好看火火根本不需要什么败般精华
你的脸就会变成了很多
给你们分享一个我看过的神器就是这个脸中精华
这个是我用到现在特别喜欢的脸值的他又能看火
又能修复还能不水的精华
我觉得他应该是我的嘴定精华
我真的是在笔记里面给你们分享过N4
他的这种制定就像两茶一样
特别好是说我是把他的当爽服水和精华
二合一度来用的
他既可以在用我们比较之前呢
来打底帮我降低翻证的精力
又可以在蓝脸的时候
给我紧急的护力
而且他的修复维度很全面
像是面上很多的修复产品
都是给你即使的做说缓震机改善革命
但是他是能做到短期内
帮你改善皮膚底下的红名谷
然后长期下来能够拔你的品账
两个更加的强认跟他砍方
像我之前脸上出了了很多
但是一整天又觉得脸总是很干脱
紧崩
我就脸序用他用了一两个礼拜之后
就恢复到一个正常的状态
而且我脸上使用平衡之后
脸上出油也没有那么多的
然后最近还受到很多节目
给我快快说
他对于你一骂斗和红正斗的改善革命
很好
我觉得就是因为你皮肤底下的那个红火
没有那么忘了之后
你就没有那么容易长的鞋饭起按照的斗
第二件就是只要过了25
所以上的油皮
我们呼呼呼之后里面
就一定要加上黑老和黑暗化
尤其是特别安掌斗的节目
要你的皮肤底下火火
对于几周跟火山一样
它会加速我们交圆淡白的流石
那黑暗化和黑暗
能让我们的脸不能一块掉
但是我们油皮就一定要选那种
非常清爽
又不会那么多的产
绿中面上是我气金维持
用下来最清爽
但是黑暗化和黑老酸我有很好的
有很多油皮姐没都开排有面上
昨天我推荐鲁业
很担心面双会厚重轰脸
但是我强力很建议
你们去试试这个
因为它我开之后能出致地
就跟个精华势里
我有时候玩一大图上面
有玩人圈不会觉得你
徒完之后那个脸上是
进清爽
但是又有一些水认感
而且它用起来的效果
也是完全不输给我之前
如果那些千元级别的大排
它除了可以把我剪上
皮肤底下的火火火
遭遇的流石之外
它更厉害的地方
是可以把我们提升皮肤的
NAAD家
像NAAD家
它可以提高我们细胞的火力
加靠我们细胞的新成单线
让我们皮肤干起来更加的年轻
这两年其实很多恢复的
可以要面双面都用了这种技术
简单来说
它就像我们皮肤的营作
发电站
可以源源不断的工店
让皮肤这个工厂
更好的命座下去
所以用它
就相当于是
一遍帮我们收工业服
一遍帮我们高效的
可以老片化
特别适合我们这种游戏
相当以前
就是不太注重
可以要化
所以保障起碗脸
然后皮肤是很亮的
但是到了晚上的时候
就暗沉的跟个焦糖
但是我用它的
就像时间那点
我明显感用的皮肤
变得很穩定
而且头脑到大碗脸
都跟着水煮蛋
摸起来很细腻的皮肤
我觉得你不是经常
熬夜直播
然后还要准备直播的东西
但是你们看我的皮肤狀態
我觉得还是保持的
就比好的
而且像它两这一套是早晚
都可以用的
先用栗中心化
打底
再用栗中片上做风险
你中间像加上什么酸心化
或者是黑纯
也可以用它买着配合
减少我们翻成个经兵
日常呢
你再做好心情
和耍杆的膚致
真的会提升的
特别特别的快
由于节门
你们赶快势意
使用非常期待
你们丢的饭愧